let's hear from a couple of other people
why don't we go next to colin from
oregon colin welcome
hi david how are you thank you for
having me on the air pleasure i have a
few oh yes thank you i have a few
questions to ask you if that's okay well
let's see what the first one is and then
we'll evaluate
i'm curious about how you feel about the
west coast's relevance to politics
um uh well let me so uh do you mean just
because
with those three left-leaning states
that are reliably left-leaning at the
federal level like does it does does it
make a difference what happens in the
states is that sort of what you're
saying yeah
yeah so we hear i know you live on the
east coast um or you know you're a world
traveler that's kind of remarkable in my
opinion but we we talk about a lot ohio
and iowa and a lot of these caucuses and
we decide that these midwestern states
really decide the abandoned fold of
which direction the federal court and
the federal
um
government liens but the west coast so
gavin newsom is making all these
big appearances but the west coast also
made claims saying like we're not gonna
corroborate with these states that are
anti-abortion we're not gonna cooperate
um
yeah what do you think about that i
think that the west coast is is relevant
and i have to you know no offense to
washington and oregon
but california is an absolute behemoth
economically and culturally and so yes i
mean you've got this state that is
really like a country it's got a larger
population and a larger land area than
many countries around the world running
the state of california is a bigger job
than running many countries and that is
of massive and significant importance um
and so i do think that
in particular california i'm not i'm not
putting down washington and oregon but
it's such a behemoth that it is an
economic leader it is a cultural leader
it is also a media leader and so i think
it's of a massive consequence an impact
so you think that
my next question is
do you really follow western politics
closely or is it kind of on your side
sides more like okay i'll check that out
every once in a while or is it really
important to you no listen i mean i
don't follow the internal politics of
oregon
any more or less than i follow the
internal politics of indiana even though
it's further away from me i'm not
following it less or more it's just i
think people in my position we tend to
follow what's going on locally to us
and then the big flash points and
certainly florida and california are two
of those
and then people are kind of living live
so but but it's there's no particular
reason i'm not following oregon politics
it's just i'm also not following north
dakota politics or michigan politics
yeah i just respect your opinion and
you're a political person and oregon's
politics and washington's politics they
we if you haven't noticed we kind of the
the governors came together and said we
are not going to cooperate with states
that are going to persecute people that
come to our states to seek abortions yes
do you think that's going to
strike some political strife is that
going to cause some civil divide it is
and we're seeing it because there are
states already thinking about responding
to that by saying we are going to
criminal criminalize anybody who helps
someone go to another state for an
abortion that may be legal there so that
is becoming a fight
it's really unfortunate that's all i
have david thank you thank you for your
time colin from oregon thank you so much
for the call
many good calls today many i think is
the right way to say it i appreciate
everyone who called in i can't speak to
anyone else today
but i will speak to more people very
very soon quick break and back after
this